normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is a viral video it's going around
Hammer attack on a painting in the
National Gallery in London oh ladies and
gentlemen we got to watch it and there
is so much to be said about this video
here we
go we got a two
people smashing the glass in the
painting did not get the vote by voting
it is time for deeds and not words it is
time to just stop
oil politics is failing us politics
filled women in
1914 if Millions will die due to new oil
and gas licenses
Millions if we love history if we love
art and if we love our families we must
just stop on
here's here's where it gets say they go
and sit down now wait wait for the most
the most depressing moment and it's
right there oh he loves her you don't
just join the movement cuz he's really
attractive to freaking theater kid the
wild no she she grabs his hand though
now I'm sorry life this what I tweet I
said life must be really hard when
you're an effing idiot he says he so
there's glass on this painting and
they're not using just hammers it looks
like they're using the emergency hammers
that I think have uh special material
for breaking glass that makes sense yeah
and they're trying to damage the
painting but I don't think they're able
to because these are very very well
protected paintings but you see I'm I'm
sorry my friends he says millions of
people will die because of these gas
leases we must just stop oil it is very
basic and
simple Common Sense the irony that if
you stop producing oil doesn't
do of people will die Millions dozens of
tens of millions 60 million people will
die in 3 days W in the United States in
Europe because oil is used to produce
food to create electricity instantly we
talk about this all the time the
diabetics die overnight without
Refrigeration without the production of
oil he would not be wearing a hat he
would not be wearing glasses he likely
wouldn't be wearing those jeans the of
his shoes the wouldn't be getting laid
the
well no I mean if they got it that chick
would be all about it but they're both
so insane cultists being used for
political purposes they don't even
bother Google searching this it's like
hey guy what what what fuel is used to
drive the tractor is it produced from
oil or the bus that brought you here yo
they tried doing electric farm equipment
and it's just like people are like are
you nuts it doesn't work electric trucks
they're already having problems with it
because maybe we get to the point when
we have ubiquitous graph Polymer
batteries and we can recharge an
electric vehicle in 30 seconds like you
can refill a gas tank maybe it's
possible but right now we use oil for
everything humans a large portion of
this planet exists simply because oil
exists yeah the re you know you can
actually track the oil age and the
population boom all of a sudden we
discovered we started discovering oil
and uses for it and then the population
skyrockets and then you get the 50s and
the petrochemical boom and we're kind of
like fashion burning of oil is not good
if we never stopped just burning it all
and putting things into it and burning
them into the atmosphere we'd probably
all choke and die but we're not doing
that we're reusing the carbon so we
don't need to stop using it we need to
reuse the carbon dude Alex Epstein wrote
an awesome book about this I don't know
if you guys have ever had him on the
show he would be an awesome guest he
wrote a book called fossil future and it
was basically making the case that just
what you said more people would die if
we actually did these green energy deals
and if we did this because the third
world countries are the ones that rely
on fossil fuels the most even though
they're not the greatest culprit of
pollution but they rely on it the most
because it's the cheapest form of energy
so if you're going to when we do things
internationally like force third world
countries to obey our sort of green
standards in exchange for funding and
money and stuff it actually could lead
to a catastrophic amount of death for
people that rely on things like gas for
heat it's I don't know if I don't know
if I you could say it's the cheapest
it's the highest energy return so uh you
know a cow is a form of energy you can
use a cow to pull you know tomt farming
equipment to like se you know to like
you know Harvest a field or something
like that but you know that's not as
efficient as oil so it's that you get
way more energy out of oil now look
there there's an issue you if you look
at global population it's very steady
and then right at the turn of the
century 1900s it skyrockets and just
goes exponential and that's due to oil
we were all of a sudden able to
mass-produce food much much more quickly
everyone became very fat and happy and
people have lots and lots of babies and
so this results in a massive population
boom around the world but now because
the oil went up people go up if the oil
goes down the people go down and so that
means if you just stop oil you're going
to kill dozens of millions tens of
millions we can all admit this was
incredibly lazy they they came up with
this fun slogan just stop oil they put
on a bunch of t-shirts they got their
little tool to B the glass I mean I miss
that guy who super glued himself to a
Starbucks cter like these people like
they brought a friend to film them
hopefully he is that was way more how do
they pick the painting that's my
question like all right we got to have a
strategic Choice the lighting is really
good here you stand over there and we'll
sit here and it'll be great I mean I
just feel like this had no it it's it's
not even that passionate offense so it's
no wonder that they have no idea what
they're arguing for because all they're
doing is trying to get clout on social
media there what are we looking at just
stop oil.com I mean what what are they
even arguing who sees that and changes
their mind we just watched it if someone
sees them it's like wow I love these
young actors doing something I would be
surprised if it turns out that justop
oil was funded by a bunch of oil
companies indirectly to I'm not kidding
it's brilliant psychology it's not it's
I wouldn't even call it brilliant I call
it basic like if if if you get a guy if
you get a guy in a trump in a trump
shirt and he walks around screaming he's
all super drunk and he's screaming and
then he walks up to a guy who's waving a
little flag saying help help us uh uh
Joe Biden wants to help us save puppies
and then the Trump guy hits the Biden
guy and it's on video who does that
benefit not benefit Trump right people
are going to be like oh wow those Trump
supporters are crazy this by any metric
to any social media marketing person
they filmed
this social media marketing 101 if you
are the aggressor you are viewed
negatively and benefit the the the
inverse false Flags so what they're
doing is benefiting oil companies they
look unreasonable they look unhinged
they've been what what you have those
people blocking the roads that's not
going to convin that makes people angry
so all these I I seriously believe oil
companies are like let's indirectly fund
these anti-oil NOS to make people
despise the oil protesters that makes
sense to you I mean when I see stuff
like this I think about these pieces of
art that if someone really destroyed
them we would lose them forever right
it's similar argument you make with like
the Confederate monuments right those
were a form of art that once destroyed
can never come back and so maybe you
feel really passionate about this issue
but this is a very lame protest to me
that could potentially destroy something
that has nothing to do with anything
else of course they don't care they
don't care about anything but care if
you're a viewer it doesn't make me want
to support their cause we got to refocus
it onto reusing the waste the the fuel
waste you got fuel you have three types
of fuel there's hydrogen carbon and
plutonium those are the only things that
can function is fuel the difference
between what fuel is means it can be put
into a container and moved around
carried around everything else like wind
turbines solar panels they're not types
of fuel they're just types of energy
generation but you need to reuse the
fuel waste so the carbon dioxide or for
plutonium they've got spent nuclear fuel
is what they called and I'm actually
interviewing a guy tomorrow on my
YouTube channel at 2:00 p.m. Eastern who
funds companies that are investing in uh
reusing plutonium spent nuclear fuel
turning them into things like I don't
know if he's going deep into the graph
into the um Diamond batteries nuclear
waste Diamond batteries where you put it
inside of carbon and it can produce like
10,000 years of electrical charge your
phone never needs to charge always be on
crazy right as long as we focus on
reusing the waste of fuel we're going to
be okay we can keep using the fuel Ian
can I ask you a question that's off
topic if you had proposed to a girl and
buy her in engagement rank would you
make graphine the Center Stone would the
whole thing be out of graphine graphine
is uh is a single Atomic sheet okay but
how would you incorporate graphine
because I feel like that's the only
material I could see you using it's it's
such an important part of your advocacy
uh I'd get a platinum gold silver
probably a platinum gold palladium ring
like three metal bands with a diamond so
no graphine at all I obviously don't I
don't know enough if graphine safe to
have in skin contact for long per time
that just carb I talked to a chemist
before I did that but that's kind of a
cool IDE shirts or something I have one
on right now this is graphine spandex my
pants are actually graphine as well
that's C uh it's cool they they stay
second foot of the episode I do want to
disclose I did invest in a graphine
manufacturer I fully intend to monetize
off of uh Ian's constant Shilling
Universal matter sure no no but in all
seriousness when Ian started ranting
about graphine I did buy stock in a in a
graphine company a long time ago and
it's it's like one of my only stocks
that's inov I would recommend checking
out universal matter.com it's uh James
tour one of James tour's companies where
they're flashing the graphine with
electric they're flashing carbon with
electricity in producing graphine with
it and they're mass mass mass producing
it so this this flash Jewel heating is
the future can graphine be used to make
annoying oil protesters stop smashing
things and throwing paint on people not
even graphine is that powerful
unfortunate maybe maybe you could
improve the roads
uh uh you could actually make a graphine
cover to that painting that they
couldn't crack through every time they
hit it they get electrocut they would
just find some other way of being
annoyed about something else like this
is the personality type they came with a
prepared monologue and someone who
filmed them like he led the practice
sessions though that's the wor that's
the saddest thing for that guy about
this event was that he doesn't get to
rehearse anymore well the saddest thing
about it is that he rehearsed but he
didn't Google one time anything that he
was saying it could help them he doesn't
care about it when you turn carbon into
graph trying to get laid it it it it
like holds it so it doesn't get out into
the atmosphere like turning carbon into
graphing you don't Lo it's so solid of a
material that you don't lose it in
probably went to a meeting he met her at
a bar and she's like well I'm going to
ad just up oil protest like so am I yeah
me me too I'll be there and that's
that's probably the only reason he's
there yeah that makes sense I mean this
was one of the stories that I liked from
last year which is uh a lot of the get
out the vote efforts where young women
who were on they would set their dating
app profiles to whatever City they were
trying to get people to register vote in
for their you know Progressive cause and
they would just like talk to guys like
wow you're so cute are you voting maybe
like it'd be cool if you registered to
vote and here's a little bit about this
candidate that I'm supporting it's kind
of weird wasn't it typically the men who
would try and Court the females by doing
a weird dance but now the women are
doing the weird dance to court the males
on behalf of a politician it's super
creepy I hate it do you think there was
some of that going on with the Israel
related protest that we saw a couple
days ago on DC I mean this goes on with
all protest it seem like a lot of
college kids and a lot of dudes I'm like
what is that dude doing there I'm like
oh he's probably there for some girl
right it's like you ever watch it soe
sunny yeah sometimes the abortion
episode where he's like pretending that
he's pro-choice or whatever cuz he's
just trying to get laid and then he's
thinking like they must be easy or
whatever and then what happens he's he
tells the woman the pro-life woman he's
pretending he's pro-life and then when
she gets pregnant he's like oh you got
to get an abortion like never pro-life
at all I haven't seen that one that's
hysterical yeah it's one of their super
old ones from like 20 years ago yeah
class but this is the thing I feel like
men should just be more like no I don't
like that and the girls would eventually
it might you know might not happen as
fast but yeah but they would change
their minds and listen to they're tar
weak pathetic men like this cells yeah I
mean yeah this this guy like he look
I'll try and be as nice as possible if
you're willing to get a hammer and smash
the glass on a painting and then scream
in a room of people without one time
Googling what you are saying you are not
a high functioning individual true he
must not be having an easy time of
meeting ladies right and so when this
woman says why don't you come with me
and do this thing he says okay no I'm
not saying it's absolutely what happened
here I'm just saying this is a common
thing you notice that politically men
tend to skew right women skew left men
are a little uh a little bit down the
middle and in biology ear muffs for your
kids in biology it's called the sneaky
that is the actual biolog a
biologist term for individuals who just
try and you know they they sneak in to
get laid they're there are the strong
males who succeed in courting the women
and then there are the sneaky
like r the Nerds yeah a great scene that
was that was a dark moment saw that when
I was like 16 that was crazy that movie
was messed up he rapes the woman and
then she's like wow but I liked it yeah
what Revenge the nurse you got to watch
that movie if you never seen it it's
it's like message on accident was that
supposed to be that he was the good guy
yeah like if you do a good job she won't
think it's raped that was the theme of
that so so she she he's in he's he's in
a costume she thinks it's her boyfriend
and then they do it and she's like wow
that was great he's like ha he takes off
the m ask all nerds think about his sex
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net